in this lesson you're going to learn how
to find the lateral area surface area
and volume of a prism and were to go
through three examples we're going to
start off easy and get progressively
more challenging but first let's talk
about the formulas for finding the
lateral area surface area and volume of
a prism now what exactly is a prism well
when you look at these three diagrams
here you can see a prism is a polyhedron
which means that all the faces or all
the sides are made up of polygons but
what you have is you have two polygons
that are referred to as the bases those
are parallel and they're congruent
meaning they're the same size and shape
they're separated by that height so here
we've got two triangles here we have two
hexagons so that's basically what a
prism is but when you find the lateral
area what you're doing is you're finding
the area of the sides lateral means
sides and when you find the surface area
you're finding the area of the sides as
well as the two bases and when you find
the lateral area what you're doing is
you're doing the perimeter of the base
times the height and we'll all talk
about that more when we do a net where
we unfold the figure the last concept is
the volume like if you're filling this
up with water how much water would it
hold well that's going to be the area of
the base times the height whenever you
see that capital B that means the area
of the base so let's go through these
examples and you'll understand how this
works say I take some scissors and I cut
the edge of this box right and I unfold
it what you would end up getting is
you'd get this rectangle like this and
what you have is like a top which is a
square and a bottom which is a square so
you're basically unfolding it and so
this lateral area here it's the
perimeter of the base see how that's 16
see this is 4 4 4 and 4 that's the
perimeter of the base times the height
which is 10 that's going to give us the
area of this rectangle like length times
width so that's where that formula comes
from so lateral area equals premier the
base times the height perimeter we can
see is going to be 16 and then the
height is the distance between the two
bases the two squares which is 10 that
gives us a lateral area of 160
centimeters squared so with area you
want to have units squared volume it's
going to be units cubed length is just
the units
but now to find the surface area we want
to take the lateral area which is the
area of the sides but we also want to
add on the two bases the top and the
bottom now the bottom you can see it's a
square four times four is 16 times two
since we have two of them right so
that's gonna be 32 so if we just add on
another 32 centimeters squared our
surface area sometimes referred to as
the total area is gonna be a hundred and
92 centimeters squared and then the last
one is the volume and that's going to be
the area of the base C capital B area of
the base which in this case you can see
four times four it's a square that's 16
times the height which is 10 it's kind
of like taking a stack of sticky notes
you've got a square and you keep
stacking them up that gives you the
third dimension or the volume and so
here for volume we have area the base 16
times the height 10 which is a hundred
and 60 but because it's volume it's
centimeters cubed it's like you're
filling this up with like little ice
cubes and that's how many would contain
be contained inside here now let's go to
number two a little bit more challenging
here see if you can do this one we want
to find the lateral area surface area
and volume of this triangular prism see
how the top and bottom roots are
triangles this was a square prism this
is a hexagonal prism okay so first thing
I want to do is want to find the
perimeter of the base times the height
so the perimeter the base is going to be
the distance all the way around this
triangle three four oh they didn't tell
us what that site is well because it's a
right triangle we can do the Pythagorean
theorem to find this hypotenuse the side
across from the right angle that's our C
side so we have C squared equals a
squared plus B squared C squared equals
3 squared plus 4 squared 3 squared is 9
4 squared of 16 C squared equals 25 and
if we take the square root we get 5 okay
so now we can find the perimeter it's
just going to be 3 plus 4 is 7 plus 5 is
12 so that's 12 times the height which
is the distance between the two
triangles that's 8 and that's going to
give us 96
inches squared for a lateral area now
how about for the surface area well
we're going to take the lateral area
which is the area of the sides plus the
area of the base times two since we have
a top and a bottom the only thing is is
that when you find the area of a
triangle we have to use the triangle
area formula which is one-half base
times height so let's see so 1/2 times
the base which would be three times the
height which is four remember the height
is perpendicular to the base that's
going to give us six but remember we
have two of those we have a top and a
bottom so that's 2 times 6 which is 12
then we just have to add the 12 to the
area of the size which is 96 and that's
going to give us a hundred and eight
inches squared that's the total area or
the surface area now if you want to find
the volume you want to find the area of
the base okay times the height and
that's gonna be your volume but the area
of the base we already figured out that
that was six okay for the triangle times
the height eight so that's just going to
be six times eight which is 48 inches
cubed and that's the total volume now
let's look at number three this one's a
little bit more challenging okay for
number three you might be saying Mario
can I just find the area of like each
face and then add them all up to get the
total surface area you can definitely do
that and a lot of students like to do it
that way but some students they like
using formula so that's what we're kind
of going through here either way you're
gonna get the same result but let's talk
about this one a more challenging one
the lateral area we have to do the
perimeter which is a distance all the
way around so that's going to be five
times six sides which is 30 and then the
height which is the distance between
these two hexagons which is six that's
going to give us a hundred and eighty
feet squared so that's the lateral area
or the area of the sides now when I'm
doing these sometimes what I like to do
is I like to write down the formula
first and then underneath it put what I
you know what I find and that can kind
of go back and forth and see what I'm
missing it keeps things a little bit
more organized and oftentimes students
like that a little bit better the
surface area though now we're taking the
lateral area which is right here the 180
plus two times the area of the base now
the base is a hexagon and you probably
learn how to find the area of regular
polygons in an earlier lesson the
formula is one-half the apothem times
the perimeter so let's see so 2 times
1/2 that's just 1 so now we have a
hundred and eighty plus a pathum times
perimeter the perimeter of the base we
know is five times 6 or 30 so now all we
have to do is figure out what that
apothem is so remember the apothem is
this perpendicular distance from the
center to one of the sides so this is
our apothem right there
you can subdivide this up into triangles
but this apothem let's go ahead and draw
this a little bit larger here so we've
got 360 degrees forms a circle but if we
divide 360 up into six angles here each
one of these angles is going to be 60
degrees that's the central angle if we
drop an altitude that's going to bisect
the angle so it's gonna be a 30-60-90
triangle it's also going to bisect the
side so that means this is gonna be 5
over 2 now remember in a 30-60-90
triangle the side across in the
30-degree angle we call that X the one
across from the 60-degree angle we call
that X root three and the one across
from the 90 to X so to get from this
short leg to the longer leg you can see
we're multiplying by the square root of
3 so this apothem here is going to be 5
halves times the square root of 3 now if
we multiply this out we can do a little
bit of reducing 2 goes in here once 2
goes in here 15 times 15 times 5 is 75
times the square root of 3 plus 180 and
that's an exact answer you can do this
on your calculator if you want to get an
approximation or round to the hundredths
and that's going to be feet squared now
the last part is finding the volume it's
the area of the base times the height
well we found the area of the base which
was a 1/2 of pathum times perimeter okay
for a regular polygon times the height
so we've got the apothem which we found
out was 5 over 2
times the square root of three the
perimeter is the perimeter of the base
which is 30 and the height which is six
so if we multiply that all out let's see
what we get
well 2 goes into 30 15 times 2 goes into
6 3 times let's see 15 times 5 is 75
times 3 is 2 25 times the square root of
3 and that's going to be feet cubed
since it's volume and that's an exact
answer when you're working with these
problems some of the toughest issues
that students have is memorizing all the
formulas for like cones and pyramids and
prisms and cylinders etc so what I did
is I put together a more comprehensive
video kind of covering all these
different shapes in one video and show
you how to memorize the formulas how the
different shapes are related etc so
follow me over that video right there
and we'll dive into some more of these
examples